she's an experiment good evening her
brain and her body are not quite
synchronized but she's progressing at an
accelerated
piece I do have to say just
congratulations the film is absolutely
incredible and also you're ret teaming
with your favorite director yor GH but
being on his set for this time around
what would you say would be the most
surprising thing that you sort of
learned working with him this intimately
with such a lead character
has spanned so many different I think
looks for you as an actor and also being
a producer at the same time yeah I mean
I think we we worked on this and talked
about it for years before we made it so
it just felt like such a collaboration
like I felt right by his side and like
he was right by my side through the
whole thing so I guess
um that is what I learned because on the
favorite you know I was I was getting to
know him still and what it was like to
work with him and here we were really
such a team that um yeah it was it was
wonderful it was it felt like such a
trusting great uh experience because
there was so much leadup to it and we
had you know I I knew about every aspect
of of how the film was going to be made
and um yeah take us a little peek inside
of his like sort of style as a director
because his films are such like wide
swings I just wonder what kind of
environment does he sort of foster on
set with his actors because the one
thing everyone Mark Willam have sort of
echoed is that it is totally unique to
him as a director and they've worked
with obviously hundreds like yourself I
think the rehearsal process is so
imperative to yorgo's process with
actors we we have three weeks together
we're playing we're having a great time
we're learning our dialogue but in ways
that are really unexpected and kind of
strange and um unique and
uh by the end of that rehearsal process
the actors really feel great with each
other and have a real you know kinship
and so I think that's that's a big part
of his work with actors is letting us
all feel good and trusting of each other
because he's not an overly he doesn't
really tell you what to do as an as a
director he he um he's definitely not
prescriptive about characters he kind of
wants to see where you want to take it
and then it's like subtleties and and
moments like that but
I think he just hires people that he
believes can play the roles and how he
you know what he's envisioning and and
then he sort of lets you you know
experience that together as a as a troop
like a it feels like a theater company
or something it's really it's really
special so um yeah I love that I
absolutely adore that I want to just
come for a weekend oh God you should see
it it's so
wild especially one thing I would love
for you to talk about before you get out
of here is Bella and how you sort of
found her because in that Theater Camp
you sort of played with the versions of
her character just from her speech
affectation and and how that develops
over the course of the film so I'd love
you to take us inside how you sort of
found that yeah I mean so much of it in
terms of the way she speaks was in the
script you know her and and jorus and
Tony and I after once we we're
rehearsing it and reading through it a
few times jorus an Tony and I would talk
about you know shifting some certain
things if she was in a different stage
or if things didn't track as much but
and then yor and I staged it out we we
made you know five stages of Bella's
development because if we were going to
be going back and forth like at the
beginning of the film that was all in
Baxter's house which only exists for
stage one and stage five the the
beginning and the end and we hadn't done
any of the middle yet so it was it was
really important to kind of work on the
physicality in advance but still like
have enough freedom to figure it out as
we were shooting um and then yeah the
language and and the way she speaks a
lot of it honestly was was just sort of
like trial and error as we went um
because she's not comparable really to
anybody and you know the way she speaks
and moves is is not something that you
could we just kind of had to make it up
so um but it was so great it was so
freeing to you know
I again I I trust yoga so much and so we
would just kind of like try another take
with with little things changed and see
what it's like and then um go from there
so it was it was very um it was joyous
to get to play like
that yeah I love that thank you so so
very much um just real quick though
Bella Barbie can we get a team up do you
think you and Margo could do there are
two Little Wonders I love Margo that
would be that would be awesome
this is
Bella Bella this is Mr mandles hello
[Music]
Bella first of all for both of you Mark
I I want to start with you because I
love this anecdote it was one of the
funniest things when I got to speak to
you before the idea that you didn't
think that you could play Duncan because
of how awful he is and that you tried to
fire yourself on the production um I
would love for you to talk about why
that is and maybe why you actually enjoy
looking back on it now because you were
so good at it thank
you it's good to see you again
um it scared me you know and um you
know it it's really playing against typ
in a lot or or or what what people have
come to see me as and then and then you
start to buy into that a little bit
yourself and um to really kind of push
push up against that that I was afraid I
couldn't do it honestly and and there's
juros and and Willam and and and Emily
and and I and all of euros' films and I
was just like I don't want to fail in in
that
realm and I was lit I was really
terrified I didn't know how to do it and
thank God we had the rehearsal process
where I where I could find it because I
did not know how to just step into that
and uh and and play it he did he was
there from day one he made me laugh from
day one he's being he's being
modest this is a trick no no cuz even in
the middle of rehearsal I was like do
you want to send me home Yos I I I can't
get the accent I I don't you know the
joke was Oscar Isaac was working in the
other part of the the studio and and he
kept on saying I know he's here to
replace me I know he's here to replace
me it was it was a gag was sure and one
day they all he put him up to it he
comes in the rehearsal and Oscar's like
hey
man good job but it's time to go
home you did not oh you're a prankster
Mr defo
he that's part of the bonding process it
was no I love it because look on the
other side of it
I've seen this Duncan I cannot imagine
anyone else I love Mr Oscar Isaac's but
sir that is your role you own him now
what a ver is yours uh Mr defo I want to
make sure that we we talk about this
because I know you don't like to get too
bogged down into the physical
transformation aspect of it you're an
actor it's about taking us to a
different place but one thing I do love
folks to hear about is what your guides
were with your character because he is
so Fantastical I know that yoro really
tried to keep the imagery as realistic
as possible within the fantasy so I'd
love for you to talk about some of the
influences and things he showed you for
how to bring our version of this Dr
Frankenstein to life um you know the
world was so complete there was so much
stuff to study I learned how to do
doctor things how to suture how to cut
um you could just wander around my house
and uh the the level of detail really
told me a lot about who this guy was and
uh who I wanted to be and then just the
relationship is very complex also there
was a pleasure uh uh in playing uh a
doctor uh I have medical people in my
family um somehow uh I grew up around um
surgeons and blood and labs and that
sort of thing so this was a different
role than I had ever done before and
there were lots of physical things that
helped uh with a transformation really
invited you to be someone else it's
amazing I find myself merely jealous of
the men's time with you rather than any
moral aspersion against you it is your
body Bella backer yours to give
freely I generally charged 30 Franks
well that seems low I wanted to start
with just how you sort of joined this
incredible process because I mean let's
be real after the favorite um yorgos was
not uh sort of having a bunch of actors
saying know I don't want to work with
that guy um but I know particularly with
you and Gerard it was not only your sort
of like relationship as filmmakers but
just how much they wanted to work with
you that sort of LED you to the project
so I'd love you to talk about it yeah I
mean it was it was such an honor to even
you know have a chat with your ghost and
so you know we just had this really
great conversation for a few hours and
then uh at the end he was like you know
I'm working on this film and there's a
part that uh I think you'd be good at
and uh you know let me know if you'd
want to do it and I said yeah I'll do it
and then he said you don't want to read
it first and I said I I'll read it I'm
but I'm doing it you know I don't care
like I and and I said to him I was like
dude I'll do a beer commercial with you
I don't drink I was like I will do
whatever I'll sell whatever you if I get
to do it with you I'm in so there was
that level of of enthusiasm and uh and
and yeah just really felt this this
great connection to him for sure I think
it's also so hilarious too because of
what he had in mind for you because so
many folks know you from you know both
as a writer but also as producer
starring in your own show but in a
comedic sense and not to say that Ramy
didn't have like serious moments to it
but you're playing very much the
straight man in this like you were Dean
Martin and and Emma's doing the Jerry
Lewis so as a comedian what was that
like for you to sort of play that other
side of it and um also what did you
think of Em's sort of like just such
hilarious comedic chops I mean Emma is
so funny and I think she's definitely
the funniest person I've ever been
across uh just in how fast she is and
and and how smart she is and and all the
choices that she makes and obviously in
this in this movie you know she's she's
doing so many different things depending
on where she's at in her character's
development uh and and for me I I was
really thankful that your ghost saw me
doing something totally different than
anything I'd done and this is my first
film and so to be able to do that and
and you know not just do accent work but
play this doctor and kind of really step
into something that it was like there
was a part of me that felt oh yeah I
know I can and want to act in all sorts
of different ways and uh it was cool to
not even have to advocate for myself in
that way he just kind of said no I think
you could do this and uh and that was
that was really cool
yeah so what was the hardest part not
cracking up the accent um being being
able to look Willam in the face and not
just be like what is up with your makeup
dude and your Willam defo tell me which
one's the hardest one to navigate I mean
you know to for me the hardest part was
probably leaving when when we wrapped
you know William and I wrapped at the
same time and that was just I was like
man this was just so much fun you know
even doing the accent work which took a
while it was never frustrating you know
it was always just it felt really
expansive and really collaborative and
you know William and I uh studied with a
mortician and and and you know we shot
the film in Europe and so we're just
with this mortician in Europe cutting
open you know animal organs and I was
just kind of like oh yeah this is uh I
didn't think I would be doing this yet
at the same time I I totally understand
that I'm doing you know it somehow made
all the sense in the world uh that life
would bring me
here I absolutely love it and again just
like Oscar winners Galore just sort of
littering the Oscar nominees and Oscar
winners Galore littering the entire
place but I will ask you for you sort of
stepping onto a Yos Lon set I'm guessing
you are obviously a fan of his work
prior to that what was the most
surprising aspect of your collaboration
and working with him as a director I I I
think for me you know I've always been a
huge fan of his and and you know I saw
dog tooth so many years ago and it was
just one of those I remember the people
I was watching it with were like what
did I just watch and and I just was like
this is one of my favorite things i'
ever seen you know so I have like that
kind of level of of of love for him and
I think what really surprised me from
even getting the script to getting on
you know on set was just how it was a
comedy you know and and he's so comedic
and I think there's so many choices that
he makes that takes what he does to a
level Way Beyond a comedy or or how we
know comedy but at its core it's a
comedy so I was really surprised in how
familiar it felt for me it I didn't feel
like in so many ways I felt expanded
right but in so many other ways it felt
really familiar and I think that's uh I
think that's why everyone is so good in
it because that that's what the
environment
was